I'm bringing the seemingly legit licked
outline for the very first episode of
the final season before I get right into
it let me explain to you how this leaked
outline seems to be legit way back in
August of last year I received a message
from a fan claiming that he is the
outline of each episode of the final
season upon reading it I thought it was
quite on point but my reason I did not
post it before is due to fact that at
that particular time there have been
numerous fake outlines circulating the
internet so I thought this was just yet
another fake one as well here's why this
outline that was sent to me might be the
actual outline of the final season as I
already said I receive this outlined way
back in August of last year that's
actually couple of months before Game of
Thrones starting filming its final
season that's a couple of months before
any leaked photo was taken and yet the
south and matches perfectly with all the
leaks and leaked photos that followed I
have outlines for all the episodes of
the final season and I will share them
all in the following days in today's
very I'm bringing in the leaked outline
of the season 8 premiere before I start
let me warn you once again that this
leaked outline does seem to be legit so
if you don't want anything spoil it's
time for you to close this video ok the
outline claims that the first scene of
the season takes place in the village
located just outside of Winterfell
called the winter town there the small
folk spread stories about the night king
coming for the mole and about their King
Jon Snow who allegedly knelt to Dragon
Queen I had to stop right there to say
that this part of the leaf outline has
already been confirmed by many sources
it's been confirmed in January when all
the famous news media outlets cover this
exclusive news of the opening scene
being filmed in the winter town keep it
in mind that I received the same for
five months prior
anyways winter town for those who don't
remember is very first material and he
snuck off for the stuffiness so being a
guest of the Starks and had a little fun
with Russ we also spent some Long John
out scenes there with Brienne as she
waited for Sansa to give her signal the
winter town is a settlement located just
outside of Winterfell itself during the
winter months the population swells as
most of the farmers and those who live
off the land move inside the town walls
for safety in numbers and piling
together grain stores for the area's
survival during the winter months the
population can swell as high as 15,000
full of old men women and children
making the easiest target right by
Winterfell for the nat king's army to
attack and sell their ranks and mates
back to the outline it says that bran
stark informed Sansa and Arya about what
he just witnessed he tells them that the
night King has brought down a huge
portion of the wall allowing his armies
to march south
since immediately commands the maester
to sent Ravens to karhold into Lockhart
since the Karstarks and the embers are
likely to get hit for
either castles being on the far north
since then forms them of the incoming
threat and commends them to March their
soldiers and supplies to Winterfell
where they shall stand together against
the army of the Dead
Karstarks managed to flee karhold with
all the supplies just before the army of
the Dead reaches it but the numbers
don't they're Kessel villas heart is the
most distant castle in the north and by
the time the Raven brought the news it
was too late the battle doesn't last
long even though this part of the
outline has gotta be confirmed by the
leaked photos it's also something that
manifests already saw coming brain
through his flock Ramon's witnessed
nothing in stirring a large portion of
the wall using the undead Viserion
allowing his armies to march south and
therefore he will likely inform his
sisters about it since of being the lady
Winterfell in the current ruler the
North Indian state does her job right by
sending the Ravens to either Norton
houses informing them of the breaking
news and inviting them to march their
soldiers and supplies to Winterfell
where they should stand together against
the enemy in the season 7 premiere
Justin warned Norton Lords that if the
wall shall fall the seats of house
tampering cars are likely to get hit
first vid castles being the farthest
Norton settlements in the north the
outline states that the car serfs
managed to flee the scene just before
the army of the Dead arrives while the
umbers whose castle is a bit more
distant or not so lucky
there's actually one leaked photo that
might be supporting this claim this
leaked photo is from episode 3 the
episode in which the living will fight a
night king and his army of the Dead
defending Winterfell as we can see in
this battle who participate John's army
Dana's armies the Greyjoy's we also see
the shields of house Mormont house car
circles some modern Norton houses
however there are no shields of house
amber which might be confirming that
they might be the first victims of the
night Kings conquest the outlined in
states that John and Annie arrive at
white Harbor in the beginning of the
episode vide unsullied they're seen
approaching Winterfell in its end with
the track e2 there's a couple of scenes
between John and Danny and between
Tyrion and those John and Danny agree to
keep the relationship a secret for now
this part doesn't need much explaining
after attending a truce meeting in
King's Landing Johnny Denny discussed
the plan to send their troops to the
north to find out the White Walkers and
that's pretty much what we're getting in
the season premiere this is insane
finales so John and Annie decided to
sail to white Harbor to travel to
Winterfell together in order for the
north to see Danny as an ally to their
king they're sailing to the main support
of the north with Ian's solid and once
they arrive over there they'll middle
track in the Kings Road and then try to
gather to Winterfell even though I
expected Johnny didn't arrive at
Winterfell in the first episode of the
final season I'm sure we'll still get
quite a few scenes of these two as
fellows of their crew
the Outland and continues with urine
arrives with their shapes at the Capitol
King's Landing he fulfill his promise
and has brought Cersei the golden
company we get to see their full might
with the scenes showing as many as
20,000 infantry and cavalry accompanied
by the war elephants next scene sees the
gun company's leader hare Strickland
having a meeting with Cersei to discuss
their plans they're accompanied with
urine
just before services start discussing
the war plans she praises the golden
company reputation of never breaking a
contract
continuing with the statement that she
hopes it will remain that way Harry
Strickland responds with our word is
good as gold this part has been both
expected and confirmed by leaks I need
to expand my armies my name is my hand
Qyburn has made overtures to the golden
company in Essos I know them well they
have helped us recover a significant
sums from parties who had fallen to
deeper ears it's good to hear
I too would like them to recover some
things that belong to me my garden what
is the most powerful army in Essos the
golden company 20,000 men horses
elephants I believe the golden company
is not here they're in SS SS going to
help us do you really think you're an
great orator and tale and sail back to
the Iron Islands he's sailing with his
fleet to Essos he's going to ferry the
golden company back here to help us win
the war for Westeros throughout the
previous season Cersei firstly revealed
her intentions to take her a new loan
from the Aero bank to hurt the golden
company in order to expand her armies
and then at its end sent you want to
bring them it is our own fleet so their
arrival is not coming as a huge surprise
what is surprising is that this outline
once again seems to be prone legit just
a few months after I received this
outline Game of Thrones cast the role of
her Strickland for Season eight with the
arrival of the golden company manifest
arise the Daario naharis might return as
well as nonetheless than its leader
thence last ordered to the REO and his
Seltzer company must enforce the Queen's
peace in the bay of dragons for a few
months until people choose their rulers
it's all safe to say that are in the
second son's fulfilled in his orders and
now that he is free from any contract
fans claim that there's a possibility
that Daria might come back as then his
enemy theory says that in the meantime
Daario became leader of the golden
company that is now hard to support
services campaign over Westeros however
if this leaked outline turns out to be
accurate it seems like there is not part
of the golden company or at least is not
its leader
back to the outline in the next scene we
get to see the aftermath of the night
Kings attack on eastwatch-by-the-sea
Thurmond and barracks right there
walking West to Castle black many fans
were worried about her favorite Wilding
after season finale some thought he was
dead buried beneath the snow and ice
however 21 the his voice is seen at
least one more time it's pretty obvious
the terminan barracks right instead of
the entire wall only the far eastern end
was destroyed when the leader of the
white walkers attacked and breached the
portion of it using the undead dragon
miss Aryan even though Thurman and
barrack were on that very part of the
wall at the moment of the night Kings
attack they're most certainly alive and
well and I'm not saying it only due to a
fact that both actors have been shooting
scenes for season 8
if you revised the scene closely would
notice a few details are proving that
turbulent Berg's arrived and are stuck
in the part of the world that did not
collapse once the undead dragons start
melting part of the wall image they were
standing instead of running down the
steps very Saudi our members of the
Nights Watch died terminan barrack ran
west along the top section of the wall
then they turned to see the Isis
structure crumbling in front of them
while they were standing safely on
section of the wall that did not
collapse and this is very dear colonel
yet the outline says strongly America
walking west to Castle black which is
not surprising the night King destroy us
which by the sea along with the
staircase is embedded in the wall so
they're surely not going down Thurman
and barrack will proceed west until they
reach Castle black and once they do
they've likely reunite with Ted and lead
remaining forces of the Nights work
south because there's no user than
staying on the wall anymore
the outline then stays that we see Jaime
lynnster next it says Jaime Lannister
reach the Riverlands he stopped the Dean
for the night is served by the cook hot
pie hooded man approaches Jaime from
behind Jamie doesn't seem the scene
intensifies the hooded man turns out to
be Brown the hell conversation about
Cersei there's not much to say about
this part of the outline Jaime's
shoveling north on the Kings Road and in
this scene he stops at its popular stop
for travelers for a meal a night Jaime
Tyrion had ignored it's only logical for
bran to head north as well and he mates
back to the outline which hand is both
surprising and expected it says that the
episode ends with serves his marriage
now I'm saying this ending of the season
premiere is expected it is not because
of the prophecy was told to her when she
was young it's because the season 7
finale was supposed to include this
scene as you can see the season 7 finale
Leto review that turned out to be almost
hundred percent accurate including it
Cersei miscarriage scene in the middle
of the night sir civics up in your
bedroom something is wrong
she gets out of bed and grab the lantern
to fight
that her nightgown and bed are soaked in
blood she screams the reason why the
showrunners decided not wear this
crucial scene in the season 7 finale is
most likely because they decided to put
it in season 8 premiere
they're heavy guys this isn't a premiere
leaked outline that was sent to me in
August last year months before Game of
Thrones began filming its final season